all right for the last two weeks you
know we've been talking about the eight
news now cook Insurance Burger bracket
that's right so we started with 64
businesses March Madness you're right
now we're down to the top four guess
what up today sicky's garage
Chad Duffield from Sickies is here with
us this morning to talk about uh the
burgers which is the key thing of course
you're here to make your pitch to the
voters for this bracket here uh first
tell us about sick he's down in the
South part of the valley yeah we do 50
Burgers 50 Brews we have 35 televisions
we're family friendly we're right on
Town Square just outside the children's
playground right on the activity center
if you will so anytime he comes home to
see the Easter Bunny get on the meet
with us afterwards we'd love to have you
right and we've got again 50 Burgers
was that a donut on the grill
that we brought today we brought our
namesake Burger which we call the
Sickies Burger it's a really stacked
Burger it's got a cheeseburger peppered
bacon an over easy egg two onion rings
hot sauce barbecue sauce and pulled pork
wow eat that one Burger you know I mean
you gotta just you know lean in and
switch it and get it
experiences are you going to cut this
one up for us for us
here this is our black and blue Burger
it is a brioche bun it is a wagu Patty
which we offer at the restaurant okay
blue cheese crumbles and a special bacon
that we glaze with our kicking bourbon
sauce wow
is there any other kind of bourbon sauce
than chicken well we want to make sure
that it's you know
so so why did are you why do you think
you made it into the final four well
because you know the community really
supported us when we opened we opened in
covid imagine that right thank you we
opened it and uh a place called Sickies
open in Covenant
yeah
we really try to participate as actively
as we can with Las Vegas because we love
them and they've returned the favor to
us so that's great to be here Cheers
Cheers
no I have to ask because you mentioned
in the in the break before we came in
boozy milkshakes yes and I know my ears
perked up you you know I gotta try some
talk to me about these milkshakes of
course we've got Milkshakes that we
Spike with the with alcohol and then we
really finish with cereals and candies
right so we've got a s'mores one we've
got a Captain Crunch one we've got a
Trix cereal one they're amazing
what do you use like rum yeah of course
rum vodka whiskey whatever you like
we heard about you know maybe a martini
one we can make
those martini
another interesting thing about Sickies
in any other restaurant burger
restaurant
how Burgers have changed it's not just
your meat and bread and cheese you know
you're talking about donuts and burgers
and onion rings and there's so many
different things that can be added in
that makes them taste as good as this
and people never get tired of it right
yeah no you can have a burger every day
of the week and we encourage to see it
at all so come on down we'll be there I
like the friendly atmosphere down there
too there's it's always happy and
crowded and fun and we're having fun
thanks for coming in good luck in the uh
bracket well you'll have until Sunday to
vote for sicky's garage if you want them
in the final round of the eight news now
cook Insurance Burger bracket it's
taking on fuku Burger Sickies against
buku burger and the chains in and out
taking on Five Guys so we've invited
both of those of them to come to In and
Out declined we're still waiting to hear
back from Five Guys but right now you
can vote for your favorite burger in Las
Vegas in the final four going on right
now 8newsnow.com or you can scan that
code that was on our screen right there
right there